Ron is on Facebook Dave what are your
thoughts on pet insurance if you cannot
afford to have your pet taken care of
you should not buy a pet you don't like
animals you're an animal hater no I'm an
animal lover I have two dogs we just
lost one a while back and got us back
down to two our hug went to heaven and
all pugs go to heaven of course and we
have a shih tzu and we have a golden
retriever the golden retriever can
actually talk better than some of you we
love our pets they are wonderful they
are however dogs and we have a
reasonable economic outlook on them as
animals they are not humans we love them
I always cry when one of them leaves I
cry like a thirteen-year-old girl
watching Romeo and Juliet when the dogs
leave I just bawl I love my little pets
but they are dogs they are not human and
so you should not take on the
responsibility of a pet if you cannot
afford to take care of it
well Kimo is $10,000
fluffy Angle make it you're mean no I'm
not mean it's an animal people we have
to keep our brains plugged in see the
problem is my wife grew up on a farm and
animals left every week and went
somewhere called bye-bye
and like Jeff Foxworthy said he said we
had a cat that tore up our my mom's
curtains and the next day that cat ran
away
yeah yes so Sharon grew up on the farm
and these animals were always running
away and we just understand that they're
animals we love them we have a heart
we're not mean we're not nasty people
but sometimes people have gotten so
confused
our culture about this and there's such
good companions if you're you know a
single person or you're you're widowed
or something and and you know your cat
or your dog is your issue it's one of
your best friends I get that but you
have to use your brain about this stuff
and sometimes folks don't and so you
know you know well you're a
multi-millionaire you wouldn't spend
$10,000 on your dog I might but I can
afford it and I kind of doubt it you
know I'm just you know it would break my
heart though I mean I cuz I just hey I'm
telling you man
I love those animals are wonderful and
and I like I say every time one of them
goes to heaven I just cry but that's
that's they're just animals and I know
something you're going to send your
little liberal crazy political correct
correct hate me on Twitter just have at
it just get in line you know because
that you know this is called the Dave
Ramsey show for a reason it's what Dave
Ramsey thinks about something if you
want to know what people know what you
think gets you a show that's how this
will work okay
so Ron asked me and that's what we're
doing here that's my thoughts on pet
insurance I don't have pet insurance I
don't recommend it I recommend you not
take on the responsibility and animal if
you cannot afford to take care of them
and if you can't you know and at some
point the care of them becomes
economically unreasonable given that
they're an animal and you have to look
at that and it's sad y'all I get it I
understand them I'm being smart I like a
sarcastic but it just I'm the same way
I'm just a big ol hearted softy when it
comes to them but I'm not going to lose
my mind either in the process or I'm
gonna lose my perspective on what's
really going on here hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]